have you birthday happy birthday to you
you should favorite teacher mommy or
daddy Wow
picking up some food is like a big day
out for me I might even put on some
makeup for it and probably not though Oh
duh Caesar Lindo a super miracle so as
soon as work is done and we try to you
know create a routine and be sharp then
that gives us time to play with our baby
[Music]
by Alexandre I'm stopped we're frog it
is serious lockdown here guys it's not
some kind of you know semi lockdown of
you know you can go out for a few hours
a day for a walk
it really is lockdown it looks like it's
going to continue like that for a week a
tour we know it cove in nineteen when
the tourist season was just getting
started here in Spain here it is guys
feel sorry for these businesses missing
elements - OH
Lindo a super miracle he is so kind of
the purview are you e-commerce they are
unison quad antenna let me ask you and
entertainment is aware ke which has
caused us pasando muchos autos i
construction tambien
you know forced to wear masks this is
definitely difficult for Matthew who of
course doesn't recognize people yeah
he's scared I guess Matthew has his
girlfriend yeah yeah yeah hmm I mean Dee
and I'm currently living in country
Victoria in a town called a chica I was
working full time but then dropped back
to casual just as coronavirus head so I
haven't really had much work or any work
for the past two months going to the
grocery store and picking up some food
is like a big day out for me it's so
exciting I might even put on some makeup
for it probably not though my exercise
regime has gone through the roof so I'm
hoping to be absolutely ripped by the
end of this it's also been good to just
fill in some time doing things that I
didn't usually have time for like
sitting down and reading a book that was
such a luxury that I've never really had
the time for I just dropped off a bottle
of puzzle glue to my parents you could
tell by this video versus the one a few
weeks ago quarantine is getting to me I
dyed my hair just anything to cure the
board I'm really she had daddy's famous
heart-attack sandwich which was um tater
tots bacon cheese put in a in a waffle
iron
and of course unless you know is one
year old so he had his birthday and it
was a different way of celebrating it
however we had a good time together
[Music]
that's something that his grandparents
mmm yeah don't see right just because
they have no connection with us no
contact when they see him he wants to
reach them but they are pushing him back
and does that that is not good yeah
thank you so we will see them soon oh I
know that it's given us time to slow
down and to stop our lives are always on
the go we're always going from traveling
here there and everywhere and we never
get to stop and think about how amazing
life is so for me we've been able to
slow down and that's been amazing thanks
john frieda i love the father you look
after me so we've been in self-isolation
since March 15 we've been here for two
months now since all the childcare has
been closed we moved to my parents house
and my mom is helping me taking care of
the baby behind mom oh wow me and my
husband work yeah we're we're both
engineers and work in the aviation
business which as you can expect is not
living its best days right people are
not flying and that has an impact on
everybody right so it's stressful times
you know working from home doesn't make
it easier I got a key word here which
helps a lot I can sit down or
so definitely not the same as what I had
back in the office but but pretty words
we also changed where we are having
breakfast lunch and supper on the ground
yeah
so just because Matthew enjoys eating on
the ground and throwing stuff on the
ground that has changed as well okay
okay can you focus first I've learned to
live very frugally and of course had to
move out of my house that I was renting
back in with my parents
into my hometown back into my childhood
bedroom so that's been an interesting
transition living with a lot of people
again and living under my parents rules
feeling like I and the teenager all over
again I never thought I would be so
appreciative to just actually be able to
rent a house and pay somebody else to
live in a home I cannot wait to have my
own space again and really I just want
to go to a cafe catch up with some
friends and drink a coffee because
instant coffee is just not the same this
is the minimum things that we were able
to bring and so just the basics when we
came here we thought this would you know
be for a little time and now we think he
for two months we only have a couple of
outfits that we continue to wash every
other day and this is it no fortunately
my friend was on oxygen he recovered I
saw him a couple of days ago which is
great he's doing okay we faced her we
facetimed so I was able to see him which
was nice
this is the the bus is to come into the
the ferry that comes in from Jersey
right now it's to be jammed it's not
even nine o'clock at a Monday morning
this should be packed with like a ferry
coming in every three minutes okay
there's nothing yeah I want to hug my my
brothers they live here in the same city
we sometimes get to talk to them they
parked their car here and we we talk but
we're you know far apart so I'm really
looking forward hugging my family going
out for for a walk have a nice cup of
coffee and leave all of this behind and
a drink
homework arrives on telegram from school
and then we have to download it and we
have to print it home school starting
today need to go get dressed first
before TV
[Music]
mmm-hmm give me a big smile
how'd you feel about going back to home
school
[Music]